hi everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today i
just really wanted to check out more of
kina bridge of spirits which
is uh or was shown as part of the
tribeca gamespot like digital showcase
live is what gamespot has called this
some of you may know of this game from
uh i believe it was a state of play
last year and i just thought that it
looked so cool it was like kind of
studio ghibli a little bit pixar
of definitely some zelda vibes and i
didn't even know that it was being
part of the showcase but when i saw that
it was i was like okay let's
let's do a reaction video to this one
because i think this game looks
beautiful and i'm definitely really
interested in it
um so i just scrubbed through to find
the right part of this live stream which
is an hour long i'm watching on
gamespot's youtube channel
but i have not watched it yet very
excited to see gameplay
this game looks awesome so let's do it
canon bridges spirits is a rich
compelling tale of failing adventure
with themes of trauma and loss of
forgiveness
and yes it's full of fast-paced action
and breathless battles with supernatural
foes
but the first thing that hits you when
you see it is the beauty of a debut game
from a small but passionate team at
ember labs
and how the stunning animation of its
lush magical world pulls you into a
journey
of a spirit guide trying to save a
village haunted by restless souls
but why not let you see it for yourself
let me just stop this here
he and i host a podcast together every
second thursday and i just want to say
he's wonderful and i had no idea that he
was part of this so
congrats carl that's amazing um some of
you might know him from spawn on me i'll
leave a link below to where you can
check him out he's he's wonderful and a
very very very good host and it's very
cool to just be like oh that's a friend
anyway to the gameplay here's our next
official selection
cana bridge of spirit let's do it
it really does does look very pixel
ground yourself feel the energy of the
mountain
i recognize that voice
draw on its power hmm maybe i shouldn't
[Music]
music sounds lovely
the emblem is a really small studio we
have a background in
film and animation we got our start
doing visual effects for
films
all right cool and then from there we're
doing a lot of
animated work for commercials
in between commercial projects we would
always syphon up some time to learn new
things and you know be a little creative
and over time you know we decided that
wow we have a real passion for games
um and we wanted to throw our hat into
the ring with our first project kanan
it does tell me you did not come to our
village looking for forest creatures
it does look like a game hello spirit
made by an animation studio i seek
passage to the sacred mountain shrine
we've been playing games our whole lives
together as brothers um
and the action adventure games are sort
of what we play together and
also it's beautiful yeah it's kind of
like
like reminding me of ori in vibe i feel
like
[Music]
we kind of had this idea of the rot
being kind of a force of nature that was
maybe working against you was kind of
the enemy initially and then
kind of had the thought to flip it where
the wrapper become your companions
they're so cute
big fan they're adorable
[Music]
and that's when we kind of like that is
very breath of the wild we had something
kind of unique
uh open a lot of cool mechanics
especially with the puzzles in the game
so i was gonna wonder is how do they
work mechanically
so it's kind of like pikmin
[Music]
whoa i didn't see that coming you can
just put the camera where you want it
you can tell
you can you have complete control over
what they're seeing when they're seeing
it how they're seeing it
in games how that goes out the window
people are communicating
ideas or themes to the player people who
go between those vocations say that
really often i know
matt and trey when making the south park
game spoke about how difficult it is to
do
comedy in a video game because you don't
actually have control over the timing
the player does
so making games funny without just
having cut scenes can actually be really
difficult
um also in part because you can't
control what a player is looking at at
any given time so if it's a visual joke
you can't make sure they're necessarily
looking at it unless you lock the camera
which is like
you know kind of beside the point of a
video game um
or you can't control like the frequency
at which
dialogue is given or any of a million
other much better examples that i can't
currently think of but but specifically
timing can be really difficult which is
like kind of all of what comedy's about
so
it's really interesting hearing this
from a studio that doesn't really have a
background in this of some of the things
that are really complicated and
it's not an uncommon thing for people
who go across those different mediums to
say
it's a lot more difficult we found yeah
[Music]
yeah sort of crafty in how you're
getting communication to the player
especially when it's trying to do it
through gameplay and not just like
always through cutscene
one of tara's memories i should see what
leads me
[Music]
we love creating immersive experiences
and we tried to really
think about atmosphere and tone a lot
when we're when we're in on the game
development side
just gave me chills the sound telling
and atmosphere is
a big part of our traditional medium
sort of film aesthetics
just having the world be something you
want to sit down and explore and be a
part of
um was a goal of ours from the beginning
[Music]
oh cool
[Music]
neat nice uh team of really great
animators who have worked together i
think was paramount in terms of pulling
off some of the
storytelling we want to do with the game
i love all of them we're actually making
like a 45
minute animated movie inside of a game
hi i'm really proud of the team a lot of
them come from the visual faction
animation background and kind of like
convert their skill sets from
the film and animation background into
developers on the game side it's neat
look boss fights confirmed breaking
ladies and gentlemen
during the process of making the game
okay so we're introduced to
a mutual group called money and we
actually you know jason myself went over
to bali to do
recording for the soundtrack
[Music]
one of the things that's grown out of
that relationship is uh day wise
it's the composer but his daughter aiu
is actually the voice of kana
my name is kayna what are you two doing
out here
she's never done any voice acting but
she fit right in it's okay
you have to go now
you know we wanted to make a game that
would just excite us if we saw it you
know something we would see the channel
oh yeah that's that game was awesome
yeah
so yeah as difficult as it has been nice
seeing more traditional
[Music]
it keeps giving me goosebumps dude like
i'm yeah
i'm all about this
ah some kind of spell casting there the
path of a spirit guide is a lonely one
[Music]
i think it looks fantastic um very very
very on board
obviously ps5 and ps4 and epic game
store it says down the bottom there um i
guess i can keep playing let's see if we
have a release saturday
probably not southern gothic is a
uniquely american storyteller
thank you norman reedus i absolutely
knew that because i've spoken about it
before
it's my birthday it comes out on my
birthday this year
and um yeah it's made by embellab and i
i would imagine it's their very first
game
they did make the majora's mask fan film
um that was kind of what a little bit of
what we saw there
but build a team of the little rut guys
that you have to find and collect
lots of exploration that looks so good
fast-paced combat it is a story-driven
action adventure set in a charming world
rich with exploration and fast-paced
combat players find and grow a team of
tiny spirit companions called the rot
enhancing their abilities and creating
new ways to manipulate the
environment look at it my god amber labs
strives to create immersive stories
through technical innovation compelling
characters in cinematic worlds
founded by the brothers portfolio
includes commercials largely
driven by a passion for telling stories
yeah i'm i'm really into this and it
coming from a brand new studio is also
just kind of
extra exciting i think yeah if you don't
remember this kind of
more i think this is the first trailer
this is it says 26th of february so
maybe i had the date wrong for the sake
of play
maybe it was earlier this year who knows
[Music]
it's just a very very cute looking game
i really like the tone
beautiful environments obviously it
coming from animators really it's just
really obvious this really shines
through
some cool looking bosses definitely
looks like it has a lot of heart
beautiful lighting effects combat looks
fun world looks great
very very very into it so obviously like
kind of a lesser popular game
um i'm not necessarily seeing it traffic
but something that i wanted to talk
about anyway just because it looks all
kinds of lovely
um almost like in the same kind of
universe as
ori is kind of the vibe that i get so
very on board so just thought that i
would share my enthusiasm i'm alana and
i will see you guys next time bye